there is a senator in california state
senator in california scott weiner
all nature is but art unknown to thee
all chance direction which that kansas
nazis name is weiner scott weiner
suggested in response to a texas
representative who who proposed banning
drag shows for minors this guy senator
weiner suggested
making drag shows for kids mandatory he
said quote
this guy this texas rep just gave me a
bill idea offering drag queen 101 as
part of the k through 12 curriculum
attending drag queen story time will
satisfy the requirement now this guy
scott weiner
this is not his first time proposing
this creepy sex stuff for kids this is
the guy who was pushing for easing the
sex offender requirements for people who
sodomize minors this this was a big
story what was it about a year or two
years ago
said california thinks that the law is
just too harsh on people who sodomize
minors and we need to go a little
lighter on them that's fair so not
surprised that weiner would push this
kind of thing
but now he's saying we we need to make
this a part of the curriculum and i i
get why he's doing it
i get why he's doing it he thinks that
he's owning the conservatives here this
guy gave me an idea i know what we're
going to do we're going to make this
part of the curriculum
yeah i know i know you're going to do
that that's what you've told us you're
going to do for years
yeah you're totally you're going to
totally own the conservatives by
proving that we were right the entire
time about your intentions yeah of
course you were going to do this
because a society has to have standards
and taboos because the society can't
tolerate everything and so
if we are going to cultivate a society
in which people
are
open to drag shows for everybody then we
need to do it we need to cultivate that
from a young age we need to educate
people into that idea so of course it's
going to end up in the education system
it has to
this this is one area where i think the
conservatives have made kind of a
mistake when they're talking about
the the don't say gay bill quote unquote
in florida the parental rights and
education bill
some conservatives have tried to find a
middle ground here
the the libs say we need to indoctrinate
the kids into lgbt and put them on
puberty blockers
and
the the people in the middle the people
to the right of them will sometimes say
well look
it's not about gay or straight it's just
don't talk about sex at all
don't just get it get that com but
that's that's actually not possible and
and the libs will point out no that's
not you can't that's not possible
because
sexuality is very important to human
nature so when that kindergarten teacher
reads the book to his class or her class
more likely about mama bear and b and
daddy bear
and baby bear all having dinner together
and eating a bowl of porridge that is a
kind of sexual lesson you're talking
about what family looks like what the
relationship between the sexes look like
no one has a problem with the teacher
reading that book to her class in
kindergarten we would have a problem if
the book were about mama bear and daddy
bear and daddy bear's boyfriend and
daddy bear's boyfriend's throuple
and his s m
club that he goes to on thursday nights
we would have a problem with that
they're they're both talking about
sexual relations
or at least sexual identities
the issue is not that someone is saying
anything about sex the issue is what
people are saying the issue is
the substance
and that's that's what this guy
understands that's what the libs
understand
and that's why the real conservative
position here is no there actually is a
difference and we as a society have the
right to say that certain behaviors are
normative or normal and should be
encouraged and other behaviors
maybe we shouldn't be cruel to people
because they engage in those behaviors
maybe we should maybe we shouldn't even
outlaw those behaviors but at least we
can discourage them at least we can say
they're not normal at least we should we
don't need to put them front and center
at least we don't need to force everyone
to put on the rainbow flag and cheer
along along the sidelines for transiting
the kids we don't have to do that
we can say that it's normal for a man
and a woman who love each other very
much to go get married and they should
get married it's good for them to get
married and it's good to to create
children within that marriage and there
are certain behaviors here that are good
we don't need to be mean to people who
don't who don't quite fit that mold
but a society has a right to standards
every society is going to have standards
anyway it's just now the standards we're
getting are dragged the kids to dragnite
it isn't going to lick itself does
anyone want to live in that society
do gay guys want to live in that society
no
not not
relatively right-minded gay guys
do do do the re the only people who want
to live in that society are the
political radicals and there's no reason
we should give it to them
we need to be able to say no there's a
north carolina mayor
who just finally stood up and he said no
we're going to cut it out with the weird
drag queen stuff there's a mayor in
north carolina
who said on saturday that a the lgbt
pride drag queen story hour event has
been cancelled after backlash from his
constituents this is apex mayor jacques
gilbert wow that's a very
very cosmopolitan kind of name for the
middle of north carolina
he is former captain of the
apex police department
he said the event was shut down because
the community didn't want it now he's
catching
pushback from the radical left the the
community has a right to say no to drag
queen story hour notice the community
didn't say no to the pride parade
the community has every right to say we
don't want a pride parade we don't want
that we don't that's not doesn't
represent our views here and so we don't
want that we're not being mean to people
we're not touring and feathering people
or sending them out of the community but
we don't want
people dancing around the streets and
leather and rainbows we just don't but
they're not they're not saying that
they're saying no have the pride parade
they're not even saying no drag queens
they can even have drag queens
apparently this is this community is so
liberal
so
leftist so open-minded by the
by the standards of
pretty much every society everywhere in
the world where they drew the line was
don't
bring the kids specifically to watch the
drag queens dance around and read them
stories
just leave the little kids out of it and
that that's too much for the radical
left that's how far the overton window
has shifted that's how far back into the
corner conservatives have been pushed
that now the fight we're having is hey
maybe wait till the kid turns seven to
trans him to expose him to drag queen
shows
hey maybe don't maybe don't let the kid
go into the it's not going to lick
itself show until he gets a lit just a
little tiny bit older
do you realize how much ground we've
lost there
the reason we've lost that ground is
because we've been duped by the left
into believing that we don't have any
right to articulate standards those guys
are articulating standards why aren't we
allowed to do it they're articulating
bad standards why can't we articulate
good standards i'm glad you like that
clip now
smash and click and ring
and subscribe and you will get the
notifications for all of our new videos
coming out also head on over to apple
podcast spotify stutter google play
wherever you get your audio podcasts
subscribe to the michael knowles show
leave a five star review we'll see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]